now during now what year was this that
you finally
got caught by the fbi and cooperated
88 plus 9 97 okay
97
so during your years when you were still
working
with the kgb did you ever have any
communication or any kind of run-ins
with vladimir putin
no no vladimir uh was he working in
germany
he he was stationed in germany in a in a
city that was uh is
about 60 miles from where i grew up i
grew up in a small village but that was
one of the closest cities
he got there in 85 i was already here
for an 85. okay so you never had any
sort of communication and
but
just
to volunteer some information about what
he did there
uh
he would have been the kind of person
that let's say if i study in dresden
it's a good possibility that he
would have been the one who i
would be working with
because the fellow that
worked with me
was
was a generalist you know
they
in in these outposts
they didn't do a lot of espionage work
and it was east germany who you don't
spy on the east germans right you
maintain a relationship with a stasi
um
you may meet somebody from west germany
who comes to visit or you may actually
you know operate as a courier for a
little bit but most of the work was uh
maintenance
bureaucratic work and working with
trainees like me right and so this is
what putin did i guarantee you
he was mid-level he wasn't even in
charge
right and so the the myth that
is floating around about putin the
10-foot tall kgb agent is is exactly
that it's a myth unfortunately a lot of
americans have bought into this
uh a lot of the top-level politicians
would and and journalists when i first
got interviewed about this ukraine thing
uh
the interview always started so
how did the kgb
uh the time in the kgb enable vladimir
putin to do what he's doing now and i my
answer is
not at all right the only thing that
helped him having
been a
member of the kgb
he networked with people who when when
the soviet union
went bust
and when
the industry was privatized
and when there was politics that you
could get into
guess who
who had the best chances because
kgb hired nothing but you know the top
top people the elite and kgb actually a
lot of kgb knew how the west functions
and how you can you know become a
capitalist or an oligarch so this this
network
there's still
residues of that network that works with
vladimir but all the other stuff that
this his ability to manipulate and play
chess and uh
and intimidate and be brutal that's
that didn't
that was not developed in the kgb do you
think it's possible that
the person that vladimir putin is today
is
do you think it's possible that that's a
result
of
the united states
constantly trying to
destabilize russia since you know for
decades and constantly
you know antagonizing russia
and
doing all the things that we've done you
know you could talk about like the coup
in the ukraine
and you know putting anti-ballistic
missiles and
or defense missiles that could
easily be transitioned into offensive
missiles all throughout nato and pushing
them and push backing him into a corner
so to speak do you think it's possible
that
who he's become today
is an effect of all of that history
it's an excellent question
um
first of all just to to
uh lay the foundation
uh
in the russian national psyche there is
a lot of
paranoia about being attacked because
russia since its found founding has
always been attacked
from the north the vikings
from
from the east to mongol hordes and from
the west adolf hitler the south there
were there was always war
and uh so there is a
there is a reasonably
based fear amongst russians and most
likely vladimir putin
of you know
being under attack right
um vladimir posner i don't know if that
name uh rings a bell he's a he's a
bilingual he's actually trilingual he
speaks fluent and almost accent-free
spanish and
french
german
and uh uh no russian in french russian
in in english
he uh during the time of the cold war uh
he
ran a program on on u.s television with
uh with a talk with a very very famous
talk show host whose name i can't
remember
uh
vladimir pozner
knew his stuff and he knows his stuff
and he is not necessarily
a russian russian
and he's not anti-american he has a
higher level view
and uh he gave a lecture at harvard
university maybe three four years ago
and i watched it on youtube and he
points out that uh
yes
there is at least uh
there is at least part part of what's
going on right now it can be attributed
back to
the actions and the words
of the united states
now i also believe that putin may not
necessarily
believe
the entire story but he's using it like
because his people believe it
you know you have you you you know
the uh nato expanded right in to the
border of uh uh russia
and we're not really
admitting this right now in the open
this i don't know i haven't heard any
american politician to even
address this in some way i am thinking
it is not
uh
it was inevitable
i'm thinking it contributed and i'm
thinking again it had something to do
with the lack of understanding
how russia operates and the posing
pretty much made the same the same case
in his uh in his address to harvard
and another another
interesting like i mentioned to you
earlier watching the the
six hour of sit-down interviews between
vladimir putin and oliver stone
is it seems like
he does have the best interest for
russia like whether he's putting on a
tremendously a tremendous act and being
tremendous you know being unbelievably
deceptive and manipulative and putting
on a show
you know
if that may be the case then you know it
is what it is but it seemed like
i was convinced that you know he does
have the best
the best in mind for russia and
again talking about his perspective
of the united states it seemed to be
sound
for what is for what it's worth it
seemed like it was very logical
and you know he's a guy who has to deal
with a new president every four years
and he watches this cycle happen every
four years and and his perspective on
ev you know during every us election
cycle they have to demonize russia it's
what they do we're used to this from the
united states and it just seems kind of
like
it seems kind of silly in a sense like
from his perspective looking back at the
united states as kind of like they're
just they're playing games i'm trying to
run this
country as it you know
as it should be but again you know
that's only
one perspective there's a lot of
thoughts that uh came to my mind as he
was speaking first of all he's not
stupid
and and and unless unless he ignores
history he should know that the united
states
other than
in vietnam
it's not a has not been an aggressive
country
we went to into kuwait
and withdrew
we went into
uh
iraq and withdrew we didn't take any oil
out
so
when when you're talking about playing
games
yeah he should know that these are games
right and
then american politicians have a big
mouth and and they always want to blame
uh russia and and paint russia
as the main enemy which is not the case
anymore by the way now everybody pretty
much agrees that china is
is the biggest adversary
so there's there is some cynicism i
believe under uh in in
vladimir's head
uh also one one other thing i want to
say
um
regardless of what what the contribution
of american foreign policy and military
policy was
this does not
excuse mr putin
going after a sovereign country
and killing innocent civilians and oh by
the way if he really is so concerned
about
a russian people you know he's he's
killed quite a few russians in the
ukraine for sure
and
um his uh i didn't watch the interview
but there is an article that he wrote
they probably didn't write it but he put
his name under it where he clearly lays
out what his goal is in life and it is
rebuilding
greater russia uniting all the russians
that originally were part of you know
the when when russia was formed it was
uh the organization was called uruz rus
and they had ukrainians and russians and
other uh nationalities mixed in and then
throughout history and with all these
wars you know they
they split up and then the soviet union
came back and and united them all by
force very often
and then the soviet union collapsed and
now now
what what vladimir putin wants to do is
recreate a cultural uh unified
russia
a paradise for the russian orthodox sort
of religion and uh and culture
uh and make it all good for all russians
but but there's obviously there's a
strong uh
personal
uh impetus at work here he also wants to
build for himself a monument that could
could be put next to peter the great
he wants to he wants to recreate the
soviet union right
i say russia greater russia
because there are in the soviet union
there are about a handful of uh
asian uh
republics that were
that are have an asian population he's
not so much interested in the asians and
that possibly would
create a conflict with china anyway